und muss ich ganz herzlich zur heutigen
sitzung zu sitzung mit diesem semester
und wir haben uns heute wieder ein
vorgenommen und zwar als wir haben heute
die grenzen gesetzt und in der letzten
sitzung da hatten wir das sehr sehr leid
dass versucht nämlich jahren hat uns mal
mit dem terrorismus beschäftigen
ein schwieriges thema
ich habe jetzt das erste zeigt wieder
geben ist sehr schwierig weil darauf
abgerichtet ist dieses phänomen
schrecken zu versetzen
also gewissermaßen die verluste aus dem
ja aus der wohnung durch den anderen zu
bringen
man kann sich fragen wie kann so etwas
was darauf ab dass gesunde zu stören
in den orientierungs und zerstören wie
kann sowas gerade wieder gefasst werden
ich glaube aber dass es einfach zwischen
gar kein widerspruch besteht
man muss unterscheiden dasjenige was
eine desto die rund 80 euch heißt nicht
dass es selbst orientiere
so schenken
die
ohne chaos das böse das ist jetzt so
gemacht den ich in diesem semester noch
sehr selten verwendet habe ich wohl den
begriff nicht verwenden über mixa kommt
das böse
wir können hier bewerten
kein setzen häufig wird auch der
terrorismus als frau ist eine zehn
wochen aber der anfangsphase beziehung
wirklich sein kann diese ganzen
phänomene zu moralisch gewesen die einen
mehr die anderen weniger
die führen dazu versprechen dessen
chaos was auch immer geschieht
und dann gibt es häufig die tendenz dass
man die schluss zieht diese phänomene
diese formen wenn diese form sogar dazu
führen dass ich daraus entsteht dann
ziehen sich selbst so verpasst selbst
politisch verpasst
schluss ger aber wenn ich die
unterstützung für mich dem streites
gewinnt als ich glaube aus der tatsache
dass aus einem phänomen ist im moment
chaos folgt erfolgt neben nicht dass es
selbst zu gast ist ganz im gegenteil
meine these es folgte die chaotische
immerhin stellen an jedenfalls in
chaotische und je mehr des neuen
bayerischen betrieb desto weniger gute
story orientiert ist diese form des
ungeborenen steigt wir können als gutes
beispiel braucht er gar noch lange
zurückdenken
die aufregung wieder an die anschläge
des elften september erinnern
er hat noch eine andere frau
[Musik]
dadurch dass anderes bereit fragen
die anschläge des 11 september zeigen
ziemlich genau dass es neben mechanisch
geplant im gegenteil es war höchst
vernebelt natürlich haben die damaligen
sicherheitsvorschriften
so war sie vor gericht leute die mir so
etwas nicht mehr
würde es in ihren kabinen abschließbar
dass der andere problematische
konsequenzen mit sich führt sichern
lassen
diesen willentliche bei geführten
flugzeugabsturz formen ja das ist
deswegen möglich gewesen weil die
kapitel zu geschlossen waren zwei
hälften sind einfach nicht so jedenfalls
nicht wieder zusammen
modische präsenz
in der folge desto weniger kann
und diese motivation ist diese strategie
würde ich sagen das heißt jetzt aber
natürlich nicht dass wenn wir das keine
ordner der bestehende damit den
terrorismus
schön und ganz so gar nicht dafür tun
uns keinen gefallen wenn wir diesen
traum auch als völlig offen
dunkelheit oder so aufwachsen ganz egal
denn das licht ist in new york und halb
das licht der fernen was natürlich eine
gewisse gefahr läuft ist das durchaus
eine form von rationalität und halten
auf die braucht nicht mehr hinzuweisen
die habe ich jetzt schon genügt
besprochen der hälfte dieser manier ins
leben
entscheidend gewesen nicht nur lehrer
mit dem viele miteinander zusammen das
waren aber keinen irgendwie
minderbemittelten geister sondern das
mal aus gescheiter köpfe dahinter stand
und weil sonst hätte 19
ich glaube nicht dass
von dem willkommen solche formate spiel
sich für ist im wirkungen
[Musik]
das war von der beschaffenheit dieser
form geben dass der terrorismus zu
stecken die höhe des orientieren so kam
es zu lassen heißt nicht dass es selbst
chaotisch ist mir sehr kühl kalkulieren
die apotheke und september
die haben einen tag ganz einnehme
getragen können sie anders nachlesen
aber vielleicht und frühstück genommen
im untergrund ich hab da mal ein
bisschen recherchiert und serien sind
die zum flughafen gefahren und haben ihr
ziel durch die thunder war wenig chaos
es gab ein chaos kommt komplett zum als
dieser nicht nach plan
bekanntester zucker und zu stellen sie
wissen sich ein flugzeug ist abgestürzt
es sollte eigentlich anderes ziel
wiederum angreifen aber die anderen nahe
sind sozusagen das sich der besten
geglückt
das verlief alles nach plan haben dass
das leben so spielt in dem film world
trade center und dann hat er im sommer
laden damit also ich sage nicht dass das
öffentlich tatsächlich schrieben die
gesammelten stellen da die video und
zusätzlich noch die kursieren immer bei
allen changieren zwischen kurzen
vhs-kassetten überhaupt an kursierten
und daneben ein paar stellungnahmen
versendet an der welt auch ganz
interessant diese mediale skulptur des
terrorismus der botschaften eben mit den
neuen medien nutzt seine anspannung und
wir haben da von dem einige wendete und
versuche diese argumentation struktur
nachzukommen
die diese dinge beschäftigen
wir haben gesehen dass bestimmte muster
argumentation
und ja das ist durchaus ganz durchaus
von dem spiel natürlich ist es
letztendlich nicht halt
das ist klar aber die gründe aufzuzeigen
wo jeder sich teilweise die sind gar
nicht so einfach weil sich auch häufig
die gegenseite mitzureden geschäfte
das muss alles ein kurzer rückblick
werden möchte also es bietet sich
durchaus an der ausarbeitung über den
stimmen von osama bin laden zu schreiben
wird die terroristische angriffe zu
genau ich schaue ich auch dafür nutzen
wir haben wie es aussieht
youtube darf hier zwischen aus doch ganz
nett an steigungen dürfte es werden die
letzten bleiben mit der heutigen sitzung
nämlich heute geht es um das phänomen
ist neides ich halte dieses phänomen
der schrank ist ein phänomen er fast
noch spannender als der terrorismus und
zwar deswegen weil der neid eine ganz
lange tradition hat natürlich tradition
wird auch ein bisschen tradition meiner
sinne dass es kulturgeschichtlich
theologisch philosophischen warum
natürlich auch dass der neid zu einer
art grundausstattung des menschen gehört
ich bin mir gar nicht sicher dass wenn
zb eine spannende frage ob nicht auch
tieren ein empfinden können
es gibt versuche mit primaten und da die
legen nahe dass tiere auch neidisch sind
futterneid und so weiter man sieht dass
man an bestimmten reaktionen die satire
wenn ein artgenosse in einem versuch
bevor zu stützen und zu mehreren den
ersten die aus und man muss natürlich
immer auch dass das mit dem nicht zum
anderen profis muss sekunden etwas
anders aus dem auge des menschen
betrachtet aber es gibt anhaltspunkte
dafür man könnte durchaus der liga
um nachzuprüfen ob tieren eingestehen
natürlich muss man verschiedene
baumaßnahmen sind bescheiden
auch das phänomen der eifersucht ist
serien mit dem dessen halter von bunten
verband bekommen da auch konzert
sprechen heute
ich wollte jetzt hab ich in meiner hand
darauf hinweisen dass es hierfür bietet
reuse bekannten das ist in deutschland
nicht im stich ließen die
kunsthistorische visierten verbessern
und hier
also
die media momentum monstrum das heißt es
der neid ist was ist dann prozent und
monstrum
einschränken das ungetüm der wismarer
ist ist die pest ist solche krankheiten
oder und sind es immer sehr groß
geschrieben strengen gravierend als
unsexy mal so kalt also das schlimmste
eine sehr schlimme ist eine sehr schöne
soll ja und warum dass die frage der
heutigen sitzung
wir können jetzt finden wir ein bisschen
anschauen mir gefallen die sitze
alle ganz gut was nicht so irgendwie
interessant von
natürlich hier wie ein kommilitone den
gesammelten erfahrungen sind dass diese
methode kommt nicht nur vor
diesen bildern das ist einfach aber es
gilt wieder das sehr schön
ausgezeichnet wird und die frauen deutet
darauf hin dass sie es vielleicht nicht
mehr so frisch
er streckte seine arme aus als er in
vielen reden was ich sehe diese bilden
viele titel sind der streben
da gibt es hier noch 101
doch zweiten streife im eingeschlossen
[Musik]
aber sind wir noch sehr jung
hier nehme man genauer hinschaut sieht
man aus dem kommissions das ist halt
finden während und am start
das könnte es in bezug auf die zündung
von geschichte sein
ich weise diese frau mit der hand
könnte auch super
also kaufte risikofall geschichte bei
der die geschichte ja eigentlich gar
nicht so sehr der neid eine rolle spielt
sind wir der hohen mut aber ganz
interessantes bild also und hier gibt es
noch jemand mit einer korngröße schießt
haben aus diesen erlösen
ach ja und auch noch sehen dass dieser
bau hier das sagen
[Musik]
was sind es als blätter des nervösen
blätter ja ja also vdv gilt der sicht
eines eines fließen alltäglichkeit
spieler ein problem
ja also das niemals so ganz kleine
einführung und jetzt möchte ich so ein
bisschen ein bisschen nach vielen
beschwerden und mal die ganze sache das
nahe dessen bisschen analytischer mir
hier mit ihnen zusammen anschauen und
zwar können wir jetzt hier auf die weit
verbreiteten eingehen also nur besteht
die moralischen automatik des neides
anbieten ist ein gefühl in welchem
kontext steht nein anbietern ist mein
selbsterkenntnis kompatibel
diese frage ist weil nicht ganz klar wir
damit folgendes fragen inwiefern können
wir noch neidisch sein wenn wir wissen
dass es sind welche richtung ist selbst
täuschen und dann ist neid semantisch
und pragmatisch verfasst darauf fertig
seid ein bisschen wir eingehen
das setze diese fragen die wir haben
mich interessiert wie erst mal vorab die
frage in welchen kontexten entsteht
heute gibt es so räume
das ist nämlich wichtiger punkt da alle
form des unmoralischen sollten wir immer
auf die räume eingeben
die den comics
er hat auch in der nahrung und ich würde
folgendes behaupten
der raum des terrorismus ist schier
unbegrenzt und zwar deswegen weil die
mediale ausstrahlung so gewaltig wie
auch beim elften september als die
nachbeben geben die schrecken der
schrecken des 11 september hat sich
durch den idealen bildern in luzern
gehirn eingebracht gefahr nicht er wurde
zu die fundierte zum ausgestrahlt das
heißt alle brunn zimmer drangen durch
alle kanäle dass es einmal so
und auch die tatsache dass man an so
einem jahrestag begeht
10-jähriges jubiläum alte erinnerungen
oder das zum beispiel gedenkstätte dann
auch wiederum entstehen
warum sie bestimmte begriffe prägung auf
stilisierung dafür eigentlich dazu dass
sich dieser zustand ist erschreckend und
etabliert dass der fortgesetzte durch
erinnerung hat sich wie so ein gewisses
finde ich ganz spannend dass wenn wir
das auch in der bau des terrors des
terrorismus ist eine schier grenzenlose
schatten
er nimmt alles an der dringend in jedem
noch so kleinen muscheln 1 durch einen
gerüchten hast du schon gehört dass nach
ihrer zeit mit medialen kanäle werden
genutzt
natürlich die bilder hat es explosionen
jetzt kann man sich beim nächstes mit
dem verein nicht raum nimmt der neid ein
bisschen umgedreht genannt
genau als man kann damit verbunden habe
also gegenstand des neides
also erst mal ich würde sagen hingegen
oder terrorismus ist gerichtet da nicht
so sehr auf eine bestimmte person das
ist möglich staatsterrorismus wenn es an
schrecken blieb kriegen wir auf
bestimmte personen raf war ziemlich
gerichtet die halten wir die einzelnen
ausgeprägt tendenziell während der äbte
september wäre abschlag generell einfach
diese wahllos b probe hatte
das war für wales willkürlichen und auch
die betroffenen gebäude waren wir zu
warm ausgefallen aber deutlich unter dem
begründung strategie von erst am ende
habe
das hatte er gesagt wenn wir jetzt
gesagt hätte aber das sind auch
unschuldige jetzt gestorben im gebäude
und was hätte etwas hat er darauf gesagt
das war ein statement des viel
diskutierten system
ja genau die sind alle amerikaner
staatsmedien gesteuert und sie wäre auch
ihre politiker und insofern sind alle in
betrieb als selber terrorismus könnte
mehr dritten mehr so gern mehr über
gestellt und auch der raum des terrors
scheint es sehr viel weiteres gutes gibt
bestimmte neid
man kann fragen waren die motive des
elfen sind wenn wir am ende auch leid
oft die westliche welt dem kapitalismus
wie besser und man wollte dass ich den
neid nicht eingestiegen
also was kann man sich zum beispiel kann
nicht außenseiter auf terrorismus spiel
weiterhin ein anschauen denke ich kann
man sagen dass der raum in dem sich
leidvoll zieht das der gebremst ist
warum für mit klagen
wahrlich
das heißt
neben sieben kann das beispiel eines
raumes einer situation in der es nicht
neiden typischerweise ereignet
im arbeitsleben
wie mobbing auch als glauben dass ich
drei über wege zum beliebten teilen den
zellen produzieren in situationen wo ich
wirklich
da ist und hilf
und nun kommt es nicht nur auf den wert
als wert zb aber nicht nur wenig geld
verbauen zb der musiker musikern wo man
eben gleicher intention dabei künstler
nämlich ist nein sicherlich häufig zu
finden aber auch im finanz
die werbe blieben wenn man sagt aber die
verdient fiel mehrheitlich wohl nicht
auf den außen oder wo es werte gibt mit
denen auf basis derer man sich
vergleichen
es scheint mir so mehr kontext eines
sagen dann haben sie noch andere
überlegen es doch mal jeder für sich
wann haben sie das letzte mal jemand
damit fast genau das brauchen sie jetzt
nicht sagen belegt
ich weiß sofort
es braucht jetzt gar nicht sagen
überlegen sie mal in welchen situationen
sie beneidet haben ihn eingeschlagen
und ob es immer noch sind und wenn sie
dann überlegen ob es immer noch neidisch
sind
dann stellt sich halt die frage ob in
dem moment muss ich glaube neidisch zu
sein
ob sie dann noch nicht und das wird halt
mit dem entspannten thematik und auch
die möchte frieden geben
wir haben jetzt fünf zuschauer haben
hierbei jetzt geht es gleich zur sache
der branchenweit es scheint auch ein
gewitter bleiben dass der ich mich bei
jenson button
man kann ja auch sieben zu wollen
bezüglich anderer lebensformen empfinden
ist er da schon wieder größer es nicht
auch eine reihe zwischenmenschliche
komponente geht oder in form von einer
person zu
auch auf tour gewonnen
im anderen leben brauchen
ich glaube dass es nicht die mittel für
die
[Musik]
diesmal besser also auch der terrorismus
ist gewichtig glaube heute terrorismus
ist nicht ja gute sätze fragen der
spezifische richtig ist denn nicht
ich glaube dass einheit besonders
intensiv ist wenn er ganz spezifische
gewichtig ist wenn ich jetzt zum
beispiel auf die westliche welt meine
spieler wollen
die höheren leben stehen dann glaube ich
kann nicht so zur geltung kommen wie
wenn ich jetzt auf eine andere person
und kontexten eingestellt
aufgrund eines ganz bestimmten wert ist
das wäre so eine sache
weil ich wieder auf die westliche welt
die das sind das scheint mir alles ein
bisschen frust zu sein
generell die westliche welt oder auf die
westliche welt
ich glaube dass das möglich ist dass man
neidisch sein kann
aber ich glaube das nicht anders als den
stamm spezifischen gerichtetes alle
konkreten wert hat den sieben leidet
unter einer konkreten personen
dies ist natürlich genau auf den
westlichen welt als zugeht oder als
gegenstand an sieben den wert
irgendwelche probleme schon 17 aber das
ist alles nicht wahr
deswegen glaube ich dass der nächste
im rennen kann man davon sprechen kann
dass soweit im trend den zorn auch
keinen druck so was würden sie ihm sagen
entbrennt derweil gibt es überhaupt
keine werbung über dem hyde das indem
sie gewisse eigenschaften zu spricht man
sagen die beiden vergiften oder also mir
ist das recht bekannteste mit unserer
seele vergiftet
[Musik]
hmm also wollen wir mit der zornig wird
wurde ja wie glas milch also zorn
reagierte schockiert
in röt zornesröte trat hier auf die
stirn bereitet er das was schüler darf
damit würden sie wieder das verstehen
das leid müssen stärker gewesen
die konzentrierte er auf eine person
gerichtet ist immer ein werden aber das
sei ein kollektiv gerichtet seite gab
aber das sind durch die verteilung und
den nicht ganz daran gegen reicht eben
nicht so stark statt sich also ich würde
das zu bestehen
ich glaube das braucht ein weil es im
mindesten tief sein kann
und natürlich hat dann so ein
journalisten wir uns noch im laden wie
gesagt es sind weiblich dass wir die an
der anerkennung bedeutet dass neben dann
das soeben formuliert er uns hier auf
derwesten hat sich den lebensstandard
ungerechtfertigter weise erarbeitet auf
kosten von der andere bilden das leben
des schlechten als man sieht darin kein
gerechtfertigten besitzt dieses wertes
und das ist gerecht und strand und die
auch bei denen
was ist dazu aber die strecke war ich
glaube beides tendenziell ihr
beschränkte und fokussierte auf eine
person auf einen gegenstand und kann
dadurch besonders stark aber bin aber
nicht der prozess ist es gebe auf die
semantik und problematik des neides 1
damit meine ich folgendes dann wie es
eben ist wie wir meint definieren und
was wir tun wenn wir sagen dass in einem
spitzen das will ich immer so ein paar
beispiele geben olympia-chance vor allem
schauen
sport ist aber bei den wenigen erziehen
also ich beneide ein gewisses personen
aufgrund eines bestimmten wert weil es
gutes aufgrund ihres einkommen ich
beneide meine schwester wegen ihres
höheren einkommen zu wägen ihre sehr
guten einkommens hat es wäre so als er
war und wer sind die personen die
subjekte b ist das beneide des kapitals
des lavendel und cs das wohnen in der
gemeinde tritt cs also dem gegenstand
das nein das kann zu sagen und beinahe
auch bei gewisser weise als gerechter
des landes ziehen könnte also be wird
wegen c bereit also peveling
grundsätzlich beneidet sondern aufgrund
eines wertes oder als und eine
eigenschaft der eigenschaft könnte
erzählt geschichten am besten zu geben
oder wissen ja was muss ich sein will
muss nicht nur 12
ehrlich gesagt wie könnte auch ein teil
der welt frage bisher ein preis diese
zeit in der politik beim lesen oder
könnte mir auch ein tier sein oder
können weder gegenstand so könnten
pflanzen sein kann man eine pflanze
bleiben kann man hier bleiben
das ich glaube es verstanden worden
können sie ein tier beneiden weil das
bestimmte eigenschaften hat die sie
nicht haben die selber gerne hätten
ich habe nicht aber es ist ja bitte
ja gut aber ich glaube die herzen sehr
gutes beispiel weil sie glaubt umgeben
sie sagen wenn man nichts sagt dann
schon den fall getroffen haben getroffen
hat den wir jetzt diskutieren werden von
denen ich glaube dass er eben gerade
bedeutet das nicht beleidigt ist aber
mein tag das ist ja das sagt es zu und
dass man jetzt wieder banken des landes
als pragmatisch ist ja diese wesen
sprachwissenschaftler den begriff das
ist betrifft das wenige was man tut wenn
man das sagt dass man den wörtern gut zb
tun von ihrem versagen bedeutet ich bin
heute die katze
nein
gemeint war
das ist
[Musik]
wer genau ist stark als meine these wer
jetzt worden dass ich glaube die kann
keine tiere begeben
und zwar deswegen nicht weil sie keine
freien gelesen sind die moralische dinge
vorbildung
ich glaube nämlich dass zum teil auch
immer ein gewisser in latenter
moralismus gehört sondern diese in
abrede stellt gewissermaßen tendenziell
ballistische gründen und tiere sind kein
gegenstand verloren ist und ich kann
hier nicht man hat zwar früher tiere
auch vor gericht gestellt im mittelalter
ohne grund
das gab es damals das letzte mal in der
schweiz
ich glaube im 16 jahrhundert ein haben
verklagt
dort können sie alles der wikipedia
interessante filme aber das ist heute
bis jetzt hier nicht so sind alle das
glauben dass chemische struktur würden
sie mir recht geben leiden an drei
stellen in der redaktion aber die bbc
da gibt es noch etwas anderes können sie
soll man sagen
ich komme gleich noch das waren so eine
these dass ich glaube ich direktor
überlässt muss aber deswegen gericht
man könnte jetzt folgen das sagen leid
bedeutet
man müsste jetzt noch weiter und weiter
analysten und sagen könnte man das folge
machen ich habe mit dem anwalt
arm ist wie zehn wegen dem bug glaubt
dass bsc nicht gebührt wegen die selbe
raus haben zb wenn jetzt sind die hier
einfügen
also ich habe jetzt praktisch das
bereitet aufgelösten in dem ich noch
einen zusätzlichen der stadt mit
hinzugenommen zustimmung der
finanzierung jetzt aus dem aufgelösten
habe ich eine vierstellige bilanz in dem
ich noch statt beneiden
[Musik]
ja das wäre so was genau oder weiblich
weil ich den mann jetzt in meine ich die
frauen zu meiner sicht geben weil die
produkte haben muss mich nicht mit
menschen anders mit gegen ich mich gerne
meinen kollegen anhören denn er hat als
ich weil ich genau so wie er auch hier
dass sie oder weil er weniger arbeitet
als dich könnte man das sagen zumindest
das könnte man könnte auch sagen
finde mich dass bp sie haben sollte weil
[Musik]
haben uns ja auch sagen muss eine
begründung
also was ich damit sagen möchte beneiden
bedeutungen der muss eine begründung mit
dem spiel als ich er oder sie sollten
sie nicht haben oder nicht sollten sie
aufatmen zumindest aber es geht im
vergleich mit mir weil mit diesem weile
mit dieser begründung dies negativ was
danach kommt die das dann den des neuen
aufpassen damit meine ich komme dann sie
mir gewisse moralische die mir zum
endspiel nicht direkt aber dann gibt es
eine begründung recht verdient
und die hat für mich ein bisschen was
von dieser moment ist muss noch einmal
weiter jetzt einen plan b ziehen kann
aussagen also dieses bleiben leben zählt
untersagt an einen pc ich neide meiner
schwester ihren höheren gehalten kann
man auch so formulieren aber ist
dass sie bewegen sie in einem oder aber
ist sie beten sie in einem einfach auch
so beispiel ich beneide dich um 10 5 und
ich habe jetzt genug dem zusätzlich
fallen
ich muss jetzt meinen schein erst jetzt
habe gekommen im moment habe ich zu
hause eingeladen auf dem schirm kraft
wir nehmen die noch dazu als 25 24
oder ein stern und zwar
das
sie liegen
[Musik]
ja
genau richtig meinte man könnte meinen
es könne aber missgunst soll es auch
eine kleine deswegen haben
das würde es anders lösen ab glaubt das
nicht
[Musik]
ja also mit sie am rechten biss kunst
müsste man auch noch weiter aufrüsten
diesen szenen
deswegen sagen glaubt dass pwc nicht das
ziemlich gebührt wegen oder bei vielen
sie wissen jetzt verständlich
[Musik]
die haben echt mist wäre eigentlich wie
neid man müsste das dann noch weiter
auflösen ich glaube man kann mit
missgunst oder nein zu auflösen jemand
gehört etwas nicht weiß oder da haben
sie mich das missgunst neben ihm agieren
sei diese begründung skulptur in sich
trägt ich glaube schon wenn sie jemanden
fragen der neidisch auf jemanden dann
würde der leser auch in modischem würde
sagen hat ich könnte das bessere meter
ihr gehört das nicht oder ist gehört er
mir da ist was nicht braucht man mit
diesem geflügelten wert geführt weil es
nicht das würde nicht glauben
begründung bringen und die begründung
würde es so aussieht ja weil eigentlich
ich mir bildungsbehörden oder bei uns
nie als es scheint mir so die
grundstruktur zu sein aber sie können
gerne gegenseitig und weil dies die ist
gleich und mir ist es häufig ist es so
dass man im übrigen zeigt der anderen
gehört es nicht sondern würde mich
eigentlich sagen mir gefällt es aber
häufig den tipp dazu ist der anderen
nicht zu können weil man darf ist
gehören und damit will man eben zu gleis
und wo man einmal damit auf der anderen
könnte bisher nehmen
[Musik]
ein bisschen ebene der außen
genau
[Musik]
ich hätte es auch der das muss nicht
bedeuten dass man da mit der anderen
person ist nicht gönnt aber ich denke es
geht häufig damit einher dass man das
was von einer exklusivität hat dass man
es diese andere person benötigt und
an ihrer stelle haben möchte das muss
nicht das bedeutet zum beispiel könnte
man auch sagen ich bin eine person
dauern
ich hätte es einfach auch gerne und sie
kann es haben bzw
leider sind es andere weise ist auch
vielleicht gerechtfertigt dabei gehabt
als sie sich jetzt nicht aber dann würde
man das möchte
was könnte man beklagen dann könnte ich
denke man könnte im zweiten mclaren
die sind diese ist dies könnte einmal
sich berufen auf ungerechtigkeit
dass man vermutet dass das bbc hat eine
ungerechte situation oder eben das b vom
glück begünstigt ist das wären solche
möglichen maria wir müssen einfach noch
mal passiert konkrete beispiele bringen
hören man beneidet man immer bereit
jemandem er dass sie etwas ratlos und
auch gerne hätte und das muss nicht
unbedingt heißen vielleicht dass es ihm
oder hier die ich beneide nicht gebührt
aber missgunst und neid sind sehr ich
erwarte ich glaube schon dass und
gemeinden auch ein bisschen und das
macht unglaublich so problematisch so
ein bisschen abwertung des derjenigen
enthalten ist der dtb hat wenn ich mich
damit in einem vergleich sind zb könnte
ich wenn jemand etwas von natur aus hart
größer stellen
das ist könnte ich das ungerechte
schicksal darin auch beklagt und der
andere person
dies ist natürlich im glück sofort
aufmachen implizit mir scheint er ist
das ganze leben mit dem live erleben und
gesagt so hoch wie jener in dieser
missgunst zu können
aber ich glaube dass sie darauf recht
zur richtigen das mist uns vielleicht
noch ein bisschen stärker ist oder
weiterreichenden ist als wollten sie
besonnen
welche stoffe
pro kind
das
wie könnte es noch ein bisschen mehr
weiter weil die und dicken genau wir
können einiges einsetzt ist eben nur
darum dass in der mist uns zumindest
wenig gebührt weil die köpfe entschieden
ist
das sind jetzt nur zwei möglichkeiten
eigentlich gemüt ist mir ich denke dass
das der klassischen hatte auch das
ziemlich gegönnt weil es eigentlich
gehöre geführt oder oder bei beiden gehe
auch nicht gerecht den weg zu ziehen
[Musik]
aber es ist nicht alles schlecht sind
nicht diese nicht die einzige
möglichkeit wie hier
[Musik]
als ich denke wir haben jetzt im fall
von missgunst und ich glaube nach dem
was sie gesagt haben glaube ich das leid
ein bisschen schwächer ist als wissen
dass neid auf jeden fall so was wie
enttäuschung oder staates begeben wenn
des wertes thema nicht hatte also die
struktur von ca immobilien zählen
er hätte gerne habt ihr nicht aber ich
glaube eben dass das ein bisschen
darüber hinaus werden
du bist uns geben dann komme hinzu dass
die bedeutet eigentlich hätte es aber
geben oder beeren es nicht verdient das
scheint mir das
aus dem unseres hat die dänen bisher nur
die messgrößen besondere klimatische und
jetzt wie gesagt jetzt gemacht auf 1 3
aber ist das bewegen 10 bereit
würden sie sagen das 3 1 oder 2
platzieren als volkes 3
das heißt dass die bbc leidet ein
zweiter synonymen oder würden sie sagen
12 dort bleiben
international sind logisch
könnte das sagen gegen 10.10 ist doch
ein interessent
oder sehen sie unterschiede ersten
möglichkeit jedes eher darum das wird
zum beispiel zwei regierungen haben
wobei das unternehmen einst wegen eines
charakteristik werden wir beim zweiten
den einkaufs charakter dieser tätigkeit
in der handlichen diesen nun gehen also
gut so könnte man das sagen also zwei
der geteilten 2 wer wird direkt auf den
beiden auf das neue objekt gerichtet zu
können und würde die person den träger
ist zeigt das wäre das überspringen der
ausgang ok denke ich ist okay kann man
sicherlich zu machen aber das
untersuchen wir einem 1 1
das ist sicher etwas hinten den treffen
hinaus kann das sagen dass ich angeben
standen heute sagt man das so ich meide
den lohnen
ich bin auf etwas neid ich bin auf den
lohn neidisch aber muss man immer so
auf den lohn von bieten oder nicht
unternehmen sie können zum beispiel sagt
eigentlich auch schon schneidet aber
dann sind sie auch schöne menschen auf
menschen insofern 70 schüsse genauso
naiv aber sie haben ja eigentlich in dem
schönen menschen den wir schon drin aber
ich bin mir jetzt auch nicht ganz sicher
sie haben die menschen allerdings keinen
gut aber dann könnte man eben halt auch
gegen weiter fassen die mit ihrem wissen
müssen dass man die westliche welt
einsetzt oder werden wir auch die
westliche werden sofern sie geben wohl
aber ganz ok verstehst man könnte zb zu
formulieren
der reichtum der westlichen welt ok und
dann bin ich nicht neidisch auf die
westliche welt wegen ihres reichtums
sondern ich bin unmittelbarer der
leidenschaft ist es okay stimmt zu dass
man den unterschied machen kann
aber jetzt für die frage nach der
publikation
ob also 12 143 spielen diese unterschied
zwischen 12 kanäle also quasi als ihnen
impliziert
[Musik]
der dritte satz erfolg
das 102
also ruhig
und dann
ist das wenn ich die entscheidung frage
wenn du jemand weiß dass er etwas gemein
dann hat er sie dann
oder machen wir mal behandlungsfall 5
also als akt wie folgt aus dass wenn
jemand das zu jemandem sagt ich im zug
der erinnerung beneidet
ja
[Musik]
genau ich glaube das wird denen dann als
sympathisch ansehen würden
wo ich beneide dich dauern der grund
warum ich jetzt jemand dass die ein
gefühl tages freute sich dieses ziel
dieser faktor ist die den ursache ist
der grund dafür dass vermissen und
vielleicht auch trainings kein fall von
und zwar glaube ich dass die dieses weit
ist weiß man dass die vorfertigung und
zwar haben die form von selbst allein
dieses feuer so weiter zu missgunst
besser gesagt gehört dass wir uns die
motive die dahinter eigentlich liegen
vor unklaren und die motive die hinter
seinen beiträgen sind häufig einfach
anerkennen anerkennung die erkenntnis
dass jemanden stärker besser ich weise
funktionieren und dass wir diesen
eigentlich auf der hand liegen dass sich
uns auf dringend bewunderung
das wird die nicht wahrhaben und dass
wir die nicht ertragen dass mit der
nicht nachkommen können
die anerkennung eines das wir nicht dass
die karte charakter charakterfestigkeit
haben
person etwas zu gehören und das
anzuerkennen und das die missgunst daher
wird aus dieser um dieses unvermögen der
anerkennung und das vergehen so werden
wir über dem vermieden wird
die man da aktiv eine richtig fette
gewickelt dass man diese anerkennung
person nicht weil man sich dann
irgendwelche gründe zu recht sagt
eigentlich verdient diese person
deswegen gar keinen ärger weil sie zum
beispiel aus moralischen gründen dazu
gekommen ist und das wäre dann so normal
ist ist das war mein problem ist das
einfallstor nationalistisch
kommunikation die mich - aber ich glaube
dass es die erste scheibe ist nicht mehr
auf das training sind
zumindest für hier fällt die ganze
selbsttäuschung für unklare strategie
weg wir brauchen wir nicht mehr eine
aktiv um die anerkennung zu umgehen und
ihr sagen er ist direkt aus als ich hier
haben wir es leider mit mein zutun weil
das moment mit gehweg gefallen ist
beides explizit gemacht haben sie wären
für uns ist ja eine form von super
sympathisch
ich glaube ich unternehmen hierzu haben
sie in mainz und gar nicht umziehen weil
nämlich dass im krieg gefallen ist und
dass moment de dieses selbst zum schluss
gewinnt bedeutet dass man sich
eigentlich gar nicht mindestens das
nachhaltig ist
das werden wir in meine these aus drei
bis vier folgt dass mich das nicht
sie wird aber auch schon zwei bis drei
folgt das also anschauen als wildheit
dann nicht 11 und zwar deswegen weil die
jedes erdbeben nicht total ist weil es
sonst im grabe tragen selbsteinschätzung
ist man hat die motive klaffte schirm
und drittens bisher nicht mal ne frage
volk aus drei psychologen 5 oder auch im
blick hatte impliziert 35 also arbeitet
das wegen der kälte draußen das
hinziehen könnte
das nicht unbedingt oder mich weise wie
sie würden sie aber sagen dass aus 45
euro
sie wollte aus dem pc schon von mehr als
33 ich denke jetzt es gibt den fall wo
man sagt ich beneide dich da
und tatsächlich diese person immer noch
bewaldet das gibt es aber ich glaube
dass die seltensten fällen
ich glaube es gibt so was gibt es aber
man ist auf jeden fall dann schon sehr
weit weg weil man nämlich dem er ganz
klar als solche bezeichnet hat und mehr
oder weniger da in der form von
anerkennung sich findet
[Musik]
ja wir brauchen gar nicht so konkret
werden aber richtig
[Musik]
ja als glaube trotzdem dass hinter der
scheibe wir sind als einfach
ich glaube dass wenn sie wirklich mal
bestimmt auf jemanden und sagen zudem
nicht als ende sondern den versuch
beziehen die gewissen argumentation
zu entwickeln und diesen reiz und nicht
als solchen klage das heißt wenn jemand
auch soweit ich es versucht er
sicherlich diese sachen ihren abspenstig
zu machen habe ich glaube nicht dass er
das hier nehmen das so direkt sagen hat
und ich glaube dass wir den menschen die
immer gewünscht
wenn man seine sache zu
und wenn es gegen die
wenn man es nicht genau
genommen ja das wäre station aber in den
akten der regel wenn es jemand sagt ich
beneide dich benzin dann finden sie das
direkt sympathisch
ja ja aber wen ist wahr ist das was die
sagen wenn das wahr wäre würde danach
folgen das nicht aber nicht weil es
nicht wir sind mit 25
wenn sie sich wenn sie mit der
mannschaft sind dass die personen h
neidisch auf sie was ist dann weiß doch
in person bfs unterstrich dass die dazu
neigen zu tun das aber jetzt wehtun wird
wahrscheinlich also aus und ich glaube
dass daraus ein bisschen folgt aus der
verdienst dass nicht die ergebnisse
jetzt spannender fall ich will das jetzt
auch dabei bewenden lassen
denken sie darüber nach das ist jetzt
hier semantik und über beides hat meines
wissens so bislang nicht jemand
untersucht an das thema browser beiden
implikation verhältnisse und die scheint
es entscheidet ist so jetzt kinder jetzt
weiter stützen
und zwar scheint es
eine der interessantesten drauf setzte
zu sein denn wie es gibt in dieser diese
editionen sehr viele aufsätze die sind
alle kostenlos zugänglich und es sind
anders als wikipedia sind sie sehr gut
zitiert auch immer ich sei ja immer in
meinen seminaren zitieren sie nicht aus
mit peter hat eine große diskussion
entfacht auf twitter ich mache oben
rechts jetzt einen link wo sie ein video
seiner letzten sitzung in zwei teile
steht sich dazu an ein bisschen mehr
eine kante
ok also rahmen hier jetzt umgeleitet mw
und sagt diese
ich habe es wie es kommt es in die
moschee und ist mit riesling zelle
devils sind mitverfolgt verwischen dass
welt kommen schauspiel einem chip riesen
der regionen und geschäftsfelder für die
fan initiative fc portus auf eine große
kulisse des nrw in der firma scs dienen
deshalb gehört die fans und journalisten
ein besuch im system wsb jetzt werden
controller support für stars wie andy
ist ein konzert
craig bellamy die pänz stellen sagte
klose
ein sehr komplexes und verwirrendes
gefühl auto unterscheidet auch zwischen
gefühl und emotionen das eine wichtige
frage ob wir inzwischen unterscheiden
kann
glauben sie dass unterschied zwischen
gefühl der emotionen
also haben wir verwenden wir beide
suchen
der autor hier wird dir zu sagen
[Musik]
schließlich
auf den seiten passieren kann wenn man
bis zur emotion nach diesen eher von
einer spontantat aus weil das andere
die hardware die möglichkeit häufig wird
die emotionen weiter gefasst also gefühl
länger schmerzen häufig gefühle mitte zu
räsonieren körperlich so reflektiert und
emotionen werden häufig vielleicht
wirklich effekte gefasst dass man als
emotionen dass die aufsichtlichen dass
geistiges rationales argument da kann
das haben als es zwischen kritischen
gefühlen und gedanken oder oder
rationalität und das würde ja bei den
beiden zu treffen weil selbst jäger
haben derlei templin eine gewisse
argumentative skulptur nämlich dass de
moment da einkaufen also weiter
kompliziert immer so was habe ich den
raum gibt immer einen vergleich zu
anderen richtig
also das ist der andere
dazu auf ein wert im vergleich und wenn
wir vergleiche bringen wir uns
einspielen
denken sie mal an russischen erkennt sie
sein seine stimme bei die ungleichheit
der menschen und eigenen bildung die
welt sagen muss dass vernunft zustand
mit dem naturzustand dem wir leben nur
die gesunde selbstliebe haben und das
mitleid wird also gewarnt und zugleich
sehr sehr harmonisch sagt jetzt mal
koexistieren dass dieser naturzustand
durch die verwundung zustand als durch
das auftreten der fans gespürt wird und
wir wollen der gesunden selbstliebe die
den anderen nicht abwertet zu einer
katholischen form der eigenliebe über
gehen
steigende bedeutung ebenso fehlt er sich
nur auf mich bezogen bin und meine liebe
die das andere ist reine und damit
zusammen hängt eben auch sehr weit beim
und andere vergleichen
die unser zusammenleben von den zustand
eines sehr stark beeinträchtigt hat also
damit ist eigentlich durchaus ein
argument dafür gewonnen
der neid ermuntert
auftreten selbst wenn meine emotionen
ist erfüllen wenn wir schon voraussetzen
vernunft als zusatz vergleich und eben
diesen studien in dem der welt das auch
immer noch im vergleich zum endstand
also muss so hat das auch schon gesagt
als jemand sagt emotionen sind phänomene
zwischen gedanken und gefühle das wird
glaube ich passen dann wäre nämlich
geneigt eine emotion dein zimmer dem
leid als gefährlich
mit dem hungergefühl gibt es da
überhaupt annehmen
das hat immer alles gefallen wenn er
eine vergisst
[Musik]
zum beispiel genau als neid macht sicher
sagt der platzverein die man kann auch
platz vor hunger werden ja also es kann
sich so ausüben und es kann durchaus
eine gewisse die körperliche seite geben
die auch der beginn an begleitet werden
oder wenn gewisse kühle also was damit
mit mit wärme metapher veranschaulichen
kühle mehr kälte
das sind die vier gefühlsmäßigen aspekte
von emotion würde ich sagen wäre sowas
wie vergleich struktur um
gerechtigkeitsempfinden brettern hier
auf der seite nur eine möglichkeit ist
ein trieb voll aus dem spread also
dieser eintrag vom reißbrett android ist
in deutschland jetzt geht es um die
frage wer das nettoergebnis nahm ihren
vielen glaube dass argentinien fiel aus
dem hof infirmis konfigurieren
im missions auszugrenzen fords fehlings
motivations und baden im moment los ding
gebaut werden wir geben ihr wissen ob
und wann der account element ins zentrum
ihres unternehmerischen engagement auf
die ist am ende des zentrums sanjay jha
computerfreaks eine panik vorstand felix
riesenmotivation respektiv itg von
ticketing- und instinkte und die
wechselseitigen als sentimental und das
finde ich ganz plausibel dass er jetzt
hier sagt emotion also themen sind
konglomerat symptome und syndroms
zitronen bedeutet wörtlich und kommt aus
dem griechischen
das da versteht dinge zusammen laufen
halten alle zusammen zusammen gelaufen
und zwar eben eine menge von gedanken
das gefühl und motivation körperlichen
bewegungen und ich glaube dass das
gerade in unserem aussagen als emotionen
ist ein weiter und werden als und weil
er eben auch solche dinge wie vor ort
mit zusammen im gefühl der nation kann
eben auch gern eine uns ein weil er eben
diese idee hat der rechtfertigt reisen
sehen sie das genauso und diese
motivation zu definieren und als zentrum
würden sie dann auch sagen dass man bald
eine funktion ist
haben sie keine probleme damit mit wind
sagen da es ein anderes für die
mitgeholfen hatten
ja keinen widerspruch als mir läuft vom
sondern sagt spd zu ok weiter geht's
die motion von henry war konnte
brathwaite entwurfs mwv die usa bis
maine größenordnung
das war unserer debatte vorher und
gemeinden musste ich immer auch eine
einzelne person gerichtet sein
funktionäre kann auch eine gruppe
betreffen zum beispiel kennt das
phänomen des offiziellen ist sozialen
einlassen kann
also wenn man auch eine
gesellschaftliche gruppe beleidigt als
er mit den besserverdienern
die schüler menschen oder die münchen
wohnen dürfen und nicht die die
außerhalb müssen sondern können
was auch immer ich beleidige die gänge
die es frauen die kosten sparen
und nicht wie gar nicht
so was das also man kann glaube ich alle
interessantesten rücken neidisch ich
glaube es gibt keine konstellation von
personen auf den mann nicht durchsuchen
kann
nur was müssen denn diese gemeinsam das
musste eine gruppe deine person haben
damit ich auf sie neidisch sein können
dass sie als wirklicher fan vergehen in
meinem zimmer
man kann sich dem nicht auf eine person
eine komponente sein
ich bin ja auch nicht direkt auf die
gruppe weil ich lese heute ins amt sehr
schön gecastet trail der gesamte prozess
ist mal virtuell als das ist jetzt echt
ist und noch mal zurück zur frage was
ist denn die bedingung dafür dass
überhaupt eine person des anderen
bleiben kann
ja
wichtig das ist meine mit dem das gut
alles wäre noch so zum beispiel die
bedingungen die wir hier in die
formalisierung mit rein nehmen können
also es könnte ja auch theoretischen mal
im stehen oder falls sein dass bbc
beneidet aber auch akzente und das wäre
dann auch nicht erst darum muss man zu
nehmen hat zehn nicht aber er hätte zehn
jahren kann
in der regel muss etwas sein was er
nicht hat aber jetzt wenn sie mal das
voraussetzen das tat sie nicht hat also
hat es nun nicht oder anders gesagt b
hat irgendwas muss dann der fall sein
das ist
ja michael frei ist viel zu leicht genau
wie ich glaube dem ich doch dass sowas
wirklich wirklich möglich ist es glaube
ich in ordnung weil das ist das bringt
damit ist der missgunst noch stärker zum
zum vorschein
sie kennen doch dann auch bestimmt den
fall dass jemand auch das hat oder
bekommt wie sie erste tipps und dann
bekommt niemand
und dann sagen sie ja der liebe kommt
doch nach geschlossen
ich hatte hier und das ist jetzt alles
geht das war es jetzt zeit haben könnten
ich hatte aber doch sorgen
kennen sie alles beispiel abiturnoten
anziehen sich so angestrengt um gute
naturschutz zu bekommen
ich bin jetzt hier und dann die heutige
generation damit die kriegt einfach so
ein skandal sagte ich müsse man muss
nichts erwartungen sitzt in die dritte
liga die person bekommt und sehr
verständlich sie vielleicht sogar
schlechter jetzt zählen wäre des gutes
abitur
mit trotzdem ein ziel das oder mit
goldenem einleiten wäre vielleicht
tatsächlich hier sind dass man es nicht
hat als er mit uns reden
ich habe es nicht verstanden aber auch
sagt ja
genau ja also genau das ist ein
wichtiger punkt
als es selbst wenn man es geht es
vielleicht eine forderung die art und
weise wie man bekam
es geht um die geschichte und dann
könnte man die geschichte das ziel vor
augen er einnehmen und dann mache ich
das gut auch die entstehungsgeschichte
des gegenstandes und dann bräuchten wir
leben hätte man letztendlich nicht mehr
derselbe
weil jemand der vielleicht im wege zu
stehen kommt und dann nimmt das endziel
mit einbringen
insofern hätten sie hätte man wieder den
punkt getroffen das ist eine handels
gewesen
ja wir haben manchmal etwas andere
tricks mit jedem fall das bc hat c ist
etwas was begehren vermeiden was musste
trotzdem und gegeben sein
ist das so
als weiteres intuition ich glaube dass
eine gewisse stabilität enthalten sein
muss also dass sich etwas als objekt des
landes regnet muss dieser wert auch um
die persistenz muss ausgedehnt sein also
wolken zeigen darf nicht im wächst
beständig ja es muss etwas sein das
gestand hat das dauern werde
jemand der schnell den ort wechselt und
jetzt mal in schwabing wohnen dann mal
wieder woanders hin zieht ja also ich
glaube es muss neben gewisse konstanz
dieses wertes das dass sich seine der
fokus des leiters dass der darauf wohnen
kann dass er sich darauf leben kann und
der wert nicht wächst und die person die
ihre werte nicht zu schnell wechseln
liegt der fokus muss klar gar nicht
erwehren mussten muss gestehen es wird
aus
es gibt nämlich bestimmte werte die
bestellen wechseln und die neue kurzen
zeit haben die concepta einmal bis auf
100 problemen konnte blieben
das wettbüro player also es gibt eben
per definition von einem besten
schauspieler
der schauspieler meinte sachen die sie
wiedererkennen wird der soffin samt
seines härter begründen ihre neotel echt
das amstel presse auf schenkel betreiben
hefter blumen tiere reflex in der
pensionskasse ausgelassen fast meint die
financial group kritik von distressed
experience points zeichen wie können sie
das heute versetzt wird in der rolle des
deputy seil von dem mann braucht aktuell
mit ambient design der nordhälfte würden
wissen diese krimis explorer haben jetzt
unterstrich er in einem video
das hat von mir haben gesagt wir können
niemanden auch wenn der gruppe nimmt
nicht unbedingt wollen dass er dieses
guten nicht ab das kann zb gibt es den
fall dass jemand dass wir uns gar nicht
vorstellen können dass jemand dieses gut
gar nicht hat man es so eng mit ihr oder
ist es gar nicht möglich dass ihre
aber was mich jetzt so ein bisschen geht
ist diesem moment der vielleicht ist es
tatsächlich so dass wenn sie ein
bisschen mehr umsonst hier fokussieren
aber es scheint zumindest würde es mir
da nicht irgendwas diese familiären auch
einen möglichen fall einen weiteren
nationen sein kann man nicht im meniskus
also wir können uns darin einig dass es
sagen es gibt fälle von leid und die
idee nicht impliziert wie sie
rechtfertigen ist hatte gegen dieses
motiv gibt es möglich dass wir jemand
gemeinden ohne dass peter der wurde
spielt aber es ist auch möglich dass
während der mainzer was verstehen dass
die mit mir gesprochen werden soll
schlimmer als die frage ist kurz gesagt
jeden können wir auch zwischen den
verschiedenen formen verleiht
unterscheiden und das tut jetzt der
autor hier sagt der gutartige und
bösartige form von über 20 gibt es
überhaupt gutartige form von alter oder
ist mein prinzip
sehen sie sind
keine frage wer glaubt dass es das leid
ist auch gute form von alt gibt oder
nicht zustimmen
aber das hat mir damals gesagt ihr
glaubt mir das ist auch das umdrehen so
schlecht ist genau das können wir zu
überlegen was spricht dafür dass man
meint auch etwas positives abgewinnen
ich hätte den vorschlag zb das leid uns
ansporn aus motivieren haben also
einheit bedeutet immer sich im
verzeichnis
dann haben die personen wegen eines
bestimmten ortes wenn ich auf jemanden
weiterspielen könnte nicht daraus auch
folgenden dass ich dadurch so motiviert
werde irgendwie b mit einem anderen
gegenstand zu übertreffen glauben wenn
ich dass es möglich wäre
ich glaube schon dass ich glaube dass
das im leid wenn gewisse energie hat die
sich auch in den zeiten ist
gleich
dass dies zwar dass moment de ist das
der kreativ im boot und erklärt die
motoren dieser ganzen leitung ist
debatte als wenn wir die aufnehmen
konstruktive weise nutzen
dann können wir also nicht viel gutes zu
machen scheint indes diese ganze energie
des landes gelegen habe ich habe
vielleicht jemand das funktionieren das
ist es was da den genauen weg ist desto
tiefer okay gut
das ist konstruktiv nutzen eine
wunderbar ok also auch wenn ich mal
jetzt tritt glauben sie dass man wenn
man jemand bewundert aus dieser
begründung die sind rennsituationen
gewählte besser zu werden als 1000 oder
gemeinde glaubt also wirklich ich glaube
wenn ich immer mit wunderbar
danach akzeptiert das wäre das i und
besser ist aber in weiß und verbleibe in
dieser gefundenes haltung worden mit mir
oder dem moment sicherlich aber auch
mehr bereit
ok
okay okay ich verstehe es werden im
moment konzentrieren wir natürlich die
koalition bisher nicht stellung
aber auf lange sicht den tüftler castro
und dazu führen dass sie selbst anspruch
ist nunmehr ein und ich glaube wenn man
bewunderung im lebensmittel verstehen
wie sie sagen dass längerfristig ist
dass man versucht es nachzumachen ist es
sicherlich möglich wobei mir eben
qualitativen ein stärker des antriebs
denn er hätte sein scheint die müssen
muss auch wenn es nicht nur ansprechend
schon nicht also der antrieb ist
ich glaube aber nicht ich glaube dass
etwas destruktives hat wenn man sich
ergehen
also mehr vermeiden und sich davon nicht
die grad
und ich glaube dieses gefühl des siegens
das ist dieses gefühl zeigen also was
man mit dem hungergefühl spezielle
verbindung bringt als was nämlich diese
rationale seite soll gratis auch ein
bisschen zynisch die station dieses es
nicht ertragen können sagt euch auch der
neid frisst sich darin wieder durch
[Musik]
man kann das auch nicht wenn man
ja
[Musik]
ich denke dass man sich dann aber noch
ganz genau
richtig also wer sich gräbt der scheint
nicht mehr
diese multinationale stärke zu besitzen
um es ins produktive zu finden aber
würden sie mich sein dass es eine form
freiheit gibt wo man den ein deutlich
spürt oder auch die missgunst aber
daraus neben zum motivation gewinnt dann
dort besser
ich glaube dass möglichst es geht aber
eben nicht mit
aber es gibt eben wenn vielleicht diese
dieser wert den man jemand leidet wenn
der wert so verlockend ist das enorm als
aussichtsreich erscheint aber häufig es
gibt eben zwei möglichkeiten des neides
erließ es gibt eine möglichkeit man weiß
dass man ziele nicht erreichen kann
das wäre dann die bedingung vergraben
würden sie nicht sagen dass es möglich
ist dass man
ziel für möglich hält für ein selbst nur
unter umständen und auf einen gewissen
situationen nicht zum beispiel wäre eine
untersuchung bei den vorzug und wird
deswegen habe ich sie nicht und jentzsch
analysiert
natürlich kann ich das nachvollziehen
mit den fokus das weist als wert nicht
so stark wie man kann musik fokussiert
eben wie gesagt immer auf den anderen
und habe ich denke ich und zuleitungen
endlich zu dass ich ihnen sagen konnte
ich bis jetzt auf mich und strebe dank
für mich nach etwas anderem sondern
immer so eine abwägung und diese
aberkennung der sache für mich ist
sozusagen kein geld da nichts anderes
nichts an der kenntnis darf sogar sagen
das erkenne ich dann hier steht dabei
nicht an
okay das verstehe ich als ich verstehe
den punkt dass man sagt dadurch dass
immer auf dem anderen fokussiert bin
habe ich nicht die voraussetzungen der
motivation aufzubringen
weil ich immer anderen orientiert bin um
mich selbst und das ist dann eine
oftmals dieses ungerecht behandelt
fühlen zu müssen
das heißt man stellt sich noch die frage
warum beenden
genau genommen wie das dann da muss halt
dann auch gerne in seinem selbstmitleid
und dann gar nicht
außerdem nicht zu verbessern
wenn nein als antwort sie also da ist es
passiert dann kann er das gesehen ist
das selbst ausführen kann
doch das finde ich gut zur
selbstgerechtigkeit auch und was hängt
damit zusammen trotz der massiven
bestehen habe trotz dass man jetzt also
fit ist und dann eben diese ganze
destruktiv dynamik fahrt ich bin damit
später noch zusammen und die
kommunikation mit
weil das so lange man das wahrscheinlich
und findet und dieser selbsttäuschung
auffälligen komponisten ein
sobald diese selbst welchen auf gesunden
ob das wirklich sein werde sondern dass
wir es machen können und dann ist die
beste sein
mit der weg dahin ist man kann ja eben
deswegen heute meine these einkommen
heute im ausschuss weiter lesen dass
viele interessante thematik
also das wäre jetzt in der frau also
zumindest vier würde implizieren dass
nur ein zusammen
und als es gab eine ausnahme für einen
song geschrieben haben aber wenn jetzt
eben dass man damit den weg finden kann
die frage ist halt mehr ist mit dritten
zu setzen
wenn ich weiß aber sie wird nur
bestimmte aussagen und wenn ich es weiß
dann bin ich gefeilt wurde das
destruktive eigenen als wenn ich mir
über die situation klar dann verfalle
ich nicht so schnell auf die was sehr
wir uns einig sind relativ gefährliches
was die intuitivität ich glaube nicht
als meine these ist meint oder meine
vermutung wäre das 3 auch nicht bereit
ist als meine prothese während worauf
ich hinaus wollte wäre für mich glauben
14 63
dass nun ein gesetz und nicht erst wie
es meistens ja gesehen und ich glaube
ihm dass das meine texte schluss wären
wir nicht immer weiß dass sich die
medien zählen eigentlich auch das nicht
mehr
das ist eben diese ganze welt hätte
statt hier gar nicht mehr ansetzen kann
weil in dem fall 3 wäre es sonst zu
gewinnen
die wirklich bereiten würde dann würde
das nicht das kind nicht beim namen
nennen wollte
das würde den begriff des neides mit das
gefühl dass man um jeden preis vermeiden
suchen weil es sich dafür auch irgendwie
schering hatte ich glaube dass alles um
das im besitz dieses jahr jemanden
beneidet der schämt sich auch deutlich
dass zusagen oder ist das ein punkt oder
würden sie sagen jemand der jemanden
beneidet oder wenn sie zb gesagt
bekommen du nein das du bist doch nur
neidisch auf sie oder auch ihm verbünden
sie selbst sofort in seine verteidigung
haltung geben und also in der rede und
dass er so kräfte und wie mir scheint
aufgrund eines gewissen schamgefühls
nämlich das schamgefühl dabei ertappt
worden zu sein wie ich weiß nichts zu
gönnen weil man eben nicht die jagd
dafür sich gelassen
aber zuerst noch dabei
[Musik]
man könnte ihnen jetzt noch
unterscheiden
zusätzlich war für das sie dass sich bmw
beziehen teilt das wären wir uns davon
wir haben unser gewissen erfüllt heißt
dass man auf luther sie bewegen sind in
einer braucht das war weiß welche bbc
also mich auch dass damit erleben aber
man kann das werde auch in hand ich
glaube wenn man etwas fühlt dann
meistens darum fand des neides an ihren
emotionalen zustand ist als meine these
haben wir können darüber streiten und
ich sehe ihre gegner mit der einmal
diese werden jetzt zerschlagen
das ist der fall dreyfus schließt das
wäre so eine these will ich eigentlich
heute ein bisschen spät ab ich möchte
hiermit herzlich und reduzieren soll
also ich sehe direkt mit der auch ein
bisher auf den punkt dass man
tatsächlich dessen finding das papier
habe ich erzähle und es trotzdem noch
neidisch
das geht auch aber dann wäre vielleicht
als ich bin heute ab 10
ein bisschen nicht ganz so könnte das
man immer noch ein bisschen hinter
gittern halten zu können
ja also dieser artikel wie gesagt den
kameralinse ich finde ihn tatsächlich
muss ich ihn auch sagen fast ein
bisschen nur klarer als den thomas cook
wenig die folien gemacht hat diese und
befinde sich noch ganz kurz es gibt
neben drei definitionen der
philosophiegeschichte über die kleidung
alles tut es leid ist der schmerz am
guten gelingen des achten und am glück
des anderen das finde ich ganz bezahlt
weil dieser schmerz ist man sollte doch
einig vom boden glückes davon
wohlergehen das land auf heute
vermittelt bekommt das sind wichtige
botschaft dass man das gute des anderen
auf sich selbst ein schmerz wird das ist
auch
nicht positive unter sich
um zu sagen und dabei erkannt wenn dies
erkannte ein wesen von kensington
bioware points geben sie damit das recht
von monster wider so einen aktiven
werden oberschelp bleiben das ist eine
ganz nette geste sie gehört wie lahm bis
hin zum endverbraucher
rathauskonzert würden wir doch gerade
als ganzes der verkleidung mbs erblast
demnächst und frisches chace crawford
bekannt
habt ihr glaube ich nicht den leitzins
in die mission bei der ihr tatsächlich
den verhalten dass wir etwas leiden
können dem anderen aber dieses diesen
tiefstand gelassen
nur eben es gerne hätten und die
missgunst die wir heute hier mehr dissen
täter die werden wir in dem land am
besten stören weil es auf uns ja so
schmerzhaft werden das heißt es gutes
andere zur ursache des schmerzes
wir wollen den schmerz nicht also müssen
wir das gute zerstören
die reiterin stoßen vorbereitungs mit
der märkischen durch die user denken des
varieté ross und reiter und junioren bay
prozess bin ich bin ich nicht sicher
dass die wirklich relevanten es mag
wirklich fälle geben wo es bei nichtig
ist
vielleicht geht es schon diese richtung
westen dieser wert zu kommen
jedenfalls entscheidung das ist moment
bis er daran gesetzt als wäre die
entscheidung anders sieht als das moment
der trägt dazu bei dieses williams also
wirklich gerechtfertigt
für diesen werden besetzen das sind
verstrichen da kommt der moment den
spielen und das wird dann auch zu dieser
graben und dieser dessen aktivität
einfach dass man das andere missgönnt
und negative gefühle emotionen
entwickelt ja und den thomas tuchel gibt
es auch dies unterscheidet sind stellen
wir uns gerne kommt die nächste sitzung
noch sprechen bisschen reversion eine
gutartig bösartigen haltung und dann
habe ich in der firma zu vergeben bisher
angeschaut
da habe ich muss sagen das ist nicht so
und diese debatte und den beiden also
wenn sie mehr ausschreiben
dann würde ich den thomas vermieter
nicht zu empfehlen weil er eben auch so
ein bisschen stark rezepte rezeptiven
ist als tote lässt hier eingeht
sie können schon anschauen ich bin der
zu diesen stanfour kopie der unterwelt
wesentlichen erhellend und begebe mich
seine nächste sitzung noch mal kurz auf
den hai 3 und dann wird unser thema sei
mit melodien
als ablöse intelligenter technologien
wie verleitet uns und den fraktionen war
romantisch zu handeln dass diese
die werden
hier konnten reserveteams situation
analysierte weise als es mit dem neuen
ist weil die technologie nicht nur
selbst diese werden im osten entwickelt
ein kollektiv sozusagen einer sind ein
kollektiver leitet führt häufig richtung
ideologie so weiter dann und trotz
dieser erfreulichen neiddiskussionen als
mich ins nimmt das nicht produktiv
werden von dieser szene thematischen
thematik wünschen trotzdem eine schöne
entwicklung bis zu setzen